[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Tianzi.
TIANZI CAI: Hi, Martin.
Good to see you again.
MARTIN OMANDER: You, too.
I want to ask your
help in answering
a few more questions for
me and other developers
about Pub/Sub ordering today.
TIANZI CAI: Of course,
I'm happy to help.
Let's get on with them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: So Tianzi,
in the last episode,
you introduced ordering
of Pub/Sub of messages
in the ride-hailing
app I was building.
In my original implementation,
if a user requested a ride
and then canceled that ride,
sometimes, the cancellation
would arrive before the
initial ride request,
which confused my application.
TIANZI CAI: Ah, yes,
I remember that.
You enabled a message ordering
to resolve this issue.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, you showed me
how to do that so that all
messages for a particular rider
arrive in the order
they are published.
In other words, the ordering
key is the rider ID.
Here is my code for
that, and here's
my Pub/Sub subscription
in the Cloud Console,
with the Ordering box checked.
TIANZI CAI: Very nice,
we can refer back
to your code and
your configuration
as we answer the questions.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent,
so the first question
is from Jacob on Stack Overflow,
specifically about the push
subscription case.
Jacob writes, "does cloud
Pub/Sub message ordering
mean the subsequent
message is not
delivered until the previous
one is acknowledged?"
TIANZI CAI: That is correct.
To use an example from
the ride-hailing app,
if the request ride
message by Bobcat
is published before the
cancel ride message by Bobcat,
the request ride message
must be acknowledged
by your application before
Pub/Sub even delivers
the cancel ride message.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
so does that mean
that I can create a bottleneck
if my code doesn't acknowledge
messages?
TIANZI CAI: That is
likely for Bobcat,
but it won't affect
other rider IDs.
For instance, this won't
affect request and cancel
ride messages from Starfish.
To avoid blocking
subsequent messages
from individual
riders, your code
should always
acknowledge messages.
If the message is
badly formatted
or if a code throws
an exception,
catch that exception,
acknowledge the message,
and report the error
to the operator.
Don't fail to acknowledge
an ordered message
for an extended period of time.
MARTIN OMANDER: So the second
question is from Robin Thomas,
in a comment for
our previous video.
"What's the behavior when the
publisher sets message ordering
and publishes messages
with an ordering key
and there are multiple
subscribers listening
to the same topic,
but only one of them
is interested in
ordered messages?"
TIANZI CAI: That is
a great question.
I think there are
two parts to it.
For serverless and
push, it's easy.
You have only one push
URL per subscription.
For example, in your
ride-hailing app,
the subscriber is your
service, built in Cloud Run.
Outside serverless,
however, pull
subscriptions are more common.
When multiple subscribers,
like multiple Compute Engine
instances, are pulling
from the same topic,
messages of the
same ordering key
are delivered to
the same subscriber.
You may hear this described
as the affinity guarantee
of Pub/Sub-ordered delivery.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so what
if I have multiple subscribers
pulling from a subscription,
and only one of them
is interested in
ordered messages?
TIANZI CAI: Subscribers
actually don't
control what kind of messages
to get, ordered or unordered.
Instead, this is determined
by the subscription.
If the goal is to separate
unordered messages
from ordered messages,
it's probably best
to publish them to
different topics.
In your ride-hailing app,
it would be a good idea
to publish ordered
messages, like request ride
and cancel ride messages, to
a rider's topic and unordered
messages, like when a user
updates their password,
to a different topic.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, so I think
what this means, to me,
for my ride-hailing app,
is that, one, if I
use push subscriptions
and a serverless
subscriber, like Cloud Run,
I don't have to worry
about multiple subscribers,
and, two, it makes things
easier if I publish
ordered and unordered
messages to different topics.
TIANZI CAI: You got it.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, very good.
So now, the third question.
Yesterday, in my
ride-hailing app,
I noticed that I got
an exception when
trying to publish a message.
After that, no more messages
for that rider ID, that
ordering key, were
published, so how
should my code deal with
publishing exceptions?
And this happened when I
was moving topics around
and changing permissions.
TIANZI CAI: I'm glad you
asked about it because there
is something special here.
Most publishing failures
are retried automatically,
but in a case of non-retriable
errors, for example,
if the topic has been deleted
and you're using ordering,
you shall call
out resume publish
to restart published messages
of the affected ordering keys.
You can add this code
to resume the publisher
in a try-catch block.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm,
excellent, Tianzi, now,
for the fourth and
final question,
my system has one
Cloud Run service
running in Europe and
another running in the US.
And both publish ordered Pub/Sub
messages to the same topic.
Will ordering still work?
TIANZI CAI: Yes, if you specify
the same regional endpoint
when you create
the publishers, you
can look up the list of
available regions here
and pick one from the list.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
so if I use this code
with this regional
endpoint, all messages
will be published in Europe,
even if this code actually
runs in the US?
TIANZI CAI: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great,
thank you, Tianzi.
I think my ride-hailing
app will work much better
after I implement these
tips you've shown me.
TIANZI CAI: That's
wonderful to hear.
Getting ordering right is
useful, and I'm glad to help.
MARTIN OMANDER: If you have
any questions for Tianzi or me,
please leave them in
the comments below.
Also, let us know if there are
other serverless topics you'd
like to see in our videos.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]